what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel domino
effect the most masculine host of the
pod best podcast in london in the world
it actually is i was on their podcast
the other day it was fire it's a good
podcast yeah the feminists are
definitely going to attack us that hate
group would you say you're a
conservative podcast yeah we're black
tourists now probably the first in
london you know yeah yeah because you
see in london compared to the us there's
no black middle class like you have
black people that are middle class but
there's no groups of black middle class
so it's like to say you're a tory you
may not say you're a nazi so i i don't
even know it's tourists that was they
called a conservative yeah sorry you
could tell me okay i don't know i'm new
to the british slang today so we did say
i was trying to find what we would
disagree on so
today we're talking about george floyd
you said you didn't agree with how
candace owens covered him yeah from what
i remember not that but let's let's see
i don't actually remember how she yeah i
should remember i just didn't like it
yeah but we can we'll go back in time
hello and welcome and we can just get
right into this because you know what we
smash your pass candace ella yeah she'll
get the willy wonka swag yeah she'll get
she'll get yeah an eyelid we are going
to cover today we obviously
i'd smash too that's why it's so painful
because you're just like you're so sexy
why did you have to do do georgia like
this because you're just
you just need to to say sweet things
have to cover the george floyd trial
conclusion which is that derek chovan is
guilty on all counts and i have to
appreciate people that were trying to
create a pressure campaign for me on
twitter saying i wonder what candice is
going to say even republicans agreed
that this was the right call i don't
care
who agrees that this was the right i
don't care if it's a republican i don't
care if it's a democrat i don't care if
it's a white person i don't care if it's
a black person i am not so much of an
intellectual coward that because the mob
decides something because the lie about
george floyd and the way that he lived
his life has become so big
that we just have to now accept it as
the truth and believe me this is a lie
nancy pelosi yesterday said quote thank
you george floyd for sacrificing your
life for justice
she also said quote that his name will
always be synonymous with justice
george floyd's name will always be
synonymous with justice you have got to
be kidding me and don't tell me doesn't
matter it does matter this is the most
important part that he is now becoming
synonymous with justice let me remind
you guys i've done it before right when
the media was spinning all the lies and
the media first came out and they said
oh george floyd was just getting his
life together he moved to minnesota he
got released from prison in 2014 he was
just getting his life together remember
that do you guys remember that media
depiction of saint george who was just
doing things for kids and just loved the
kids and really was trying to set a good
example and was just getting his life
together until i reminded people of what
his actual record was because it became
apparent to me that there was a reason
that they were not producing the police
footage because they wanted to make sure
that the lie was perpetuated around the
world and repeated over and over again
before we get into this she's talking
about the lion that he's not a martyr
for the cause but before we muddy the
waters and i can't remember how she
covers it they said mandela was a
terrorist winston churchill who was an
avid racist and said the deaf who's they
uh candace no no no they as in society
like how society perceives it because
basically what she's trying to do is
saying that because of the past he's not
a mark for the cause whether his past
was the past in terms of the cause of
what blm has done and has done
affirmative action and actually got rid
of say white privilege into some regard
jordan peterson would say there's no
right privilege but giving other people
opportunities they never would have had
regardless of who he was what he went to
achieve in terms of in his death and the
repercussions that he had
he was still a mark for the course even
if he was a shitty person i don't know
he held a gun to a pregnant lady's
stomach but mahatma gandhi you know
gandhi the most peaceful man to ever
live look at i don't know a [ __ ] about
gandhi
i know who he is but like don't don't
you're gonna bring up these people i'm
like i don't
know he's an important person and like
indians love him and they say yeah he's
people yeah so he used to like touch
little kids is he convicted um well and
he talks about in one of his uh writings
that he used to get his naked niece who
was like 14 at the time and he used to
test if he could stay celibate with her
sleeping next to him and he talks about
this he says he never did anything but
why are you getting your 14 year old
niece but he's like idolized as the most
important person and my point is it's
like really even though he did do some
great things yeah but he did some
terrible things but because
the british people they support his
ideas they're like oh my god he's
goodness well i think i think the point
is like they were hiding that
yeah but they hide that for gandhi
though
they russia i'm not for hiding anything
it's like mlk was killed by the u.s
government and they hid that like not me
a lot of people unless you're from the
u.s most people outside the u.s don't
actually know so okay i know i've heard
that but i've also heard that that's a
conspiracy theory no if you could google
it literally you can find it the the us
government yeah yeah okay the u.s
government i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm just saying i don't know yeah
who killed his
his family believes that james earl was
framed but that's not the same thing as
oh did you notice it says it says who
killed mlk jr
his family believes let's see findings
if we're not filming if i'm wrong i
don't know i just i just that sounds
like something that's a conspiracy
theory to me
maybe i'm wrong i believe in a lot of
conspiracy theories
if i'm wrong i'm wrong
i just oh there we go us government
found guilty in conspiracy
assassinate. and this is from news one
so it's reputable she's not coming
because i swear i did read it no i'm not
okay yeah no i'm just thinking the
government has wrapped four weeks of
testimony okay and witnesses in the
civil trial was assassin dr king was
assassinated as the result of a
conspiracy the new york times reported
the king family who filed a civil suit
was awarded
a hundred dollars yeah i see
that's it so history is written by the
victims so like
usa hear that they won't teach that in
your curriculum interesting the fact
that you're from the us you didn't even
know and i'm sure you studied oh but
this is why it's because it's uh over 70
we hold on 12 jurors and a swift um that
dr king was assassinated as a result of
a conspiracy the new york times at the
time the king family who filed the lost
civil suit was awarded a hundred dollars
they donated the
minuscule amount to charity lloyd lloyd
jones owner of jim's grill which was
close to blah blah claimed that the shot
which dr kim was fired from behind his
restaurant the local and state federal
government officials and the mafia were
all involved james earl ray who pleaded
guilty to assassinating king was renting
a room above the establishment was a
scapegoat the restaurant owner named
memphis police department earl king
as dr king's assassin according to a
press conference conference transcript a
claim that would be called into question
along other shocking details according
to the u.s justice department which
painstakingly attempts to dismantle
jowers claims and mountains of evidence
presented at a memphis child jowers
insisted that a memphis pr
produce dealer which was involved in the
mafia gave dowers a hundred thousand
dollars to hire an assassin but i think
the reason is because it's a civil trial
and i'm not yeah but i don't that when
it comes to that yeah that's hold on i
need to i don't want to
there's a civil case
yeah okay so
this is and i might be getting it wrong
but i think that's like outside of the
law like you're suing
and it's not like actually a legal trial
yeah it's it's similar to in the uk if
it's civil it's not like it's not
legally binding yeah but that's that's
why they can't say conclusively because
it wasn't tried like
in a court like it's not it's not
because they're like hiding it it's
because they haven't can like but the
fact that the u.s government are even
allowing and awarding them some
but it's not because it's not congress
but it's not the government it's a civil
right like that's that's the point all
right and so i don't think it's like
they're hiding it it's that they didn't
prove it in court you know they proved
it in a civil trial i think i think you
can correct me if i'm wrong i might get
cooked in the comments i don't know
about that one
they always think
they always want me to be smarter i'm
like i'm sorry
i know about relationships
they're like why don't you know your
history i'm like look
i know certain things about history i
don't know everything before the truth
could get up from bed and put its shoes
on and here is the truth here is the
person whose life and whose name is now
synonymous with justice nancy pelosi
george floyd has a rap sheet and i'm
going to remind you guys of it again
today
he was arrested for delivery of a
controlled substance he was arrested and
put into jail he was arrested for theft
he was arrested for theft again he spent
10 months and 10 days in jail he was
arrested for failure to identify he
spent 15 days in jail you know it's
crazy when the media said that george
floyd died they painted him as like like
they didn't have any of this in there
but when kevin samuels died they all put
in the title that like like man that
referred to him as like women as
leftovers like that was like the first
description they had of kevin samuels
and that's like a black guy who was like
doing stuff for his community he was
literally like trying to bring black
families back together in the u.s and
they hate him as the bad guy but they
put george floyd is like a martyr i
think that's her issue with it but when
with a lot of social media a lot of it
is gynocentric it's very female-led yeah
so if you hurt someone's feelings it's
almost painful
he
actually killed a man or whatever in
context and some of them were gang
leaders but as soon as he came and spoke
out against the trans and and the gay
community they killed him but when you
they were actually talking about uh
the baby the baby died no no no
they murdered him in the media and they
like tried to affect him
he killed someone but he's like okay so
talking about shooting black people and
other marginalized groups is fine but
making a joke about gay people which
hurts their feelings
now suddenly that's weird doesn't it
shouldn't killing people and selling
drugs to your community be more harmful
than hurting someone's feelings you
would you would think
he was again arrested for possession of
a controlled substance less than one
gram of cocaine he was then arrested for
trespassing no forcible entry he was
arrested for delivery of a controlled
substance he was arrested for possession
with intent to manufacture or distribute
another 30 months in jail total he was
arrested for aggravate aggravated
robbery with a dangerous and deadly
weapon and that has really got to be
the most significant arrest for me
because of how sick what he did was
ready here's a statement really the only
thing i see bad in that is the
aggravated robbery because if it's just
drugs like a gram of drugs like common
man everyone does even suits to do drugs
did she say robbery yeah i'm gonna say
robbery's the only no about the other
ones
and like over here
doing drugs is normal they even call
them nosebeasts i'm just saying like
it's not really that bad
there's men in suits you see from wall
street okay i don't like those types i'm
equal i don't like people doing drugs
it's not my thing i'm not drug dealer i
hate it i'm not do you drink no i don't
drink you don't drink no i don't drink
you've never seen me drink out the show
you're not muslim what you're not
missing no i just i think it's stupid
well if you go to dubai they'll wife you
up quickly but oh my god she doesn't
drink she's halal like you you get a
husband quick well yeah but there aren't
those the guys that are flying like
women
they live alive
you'll be the wife
don't be the poor poor you don't get
shattered
i see what's going on you'll be a queen
i'm good i'm good on dubai oh yeah a
nice little trick nice little shake you
know i always say i'll mooch off of my
dad before i say that
dad
let me come home
the bells are tiring
let me move back in with you and mom
please
at this time a black ford explorer
pulled up in front of the complainant's
residence the complaint that we're
talking about
the woman had somebody knock on her door
and say that they were from the water
department
and then that person forced their way
into her home and then a ford explorer
pulled up
and there were five other black males
that exited this vehicle and proceeded
to the front door the largest of these
suspects forced his way into the
residence this is george floyd forced
his way into the residence placed a
pistol against the complainant's abdomen
and forced her into the living room area
of the residence the large suspect then
proceeded to search the residence while
another armed suspect guarded the
complainant who was struck in the head
and side areas by the second armed
suspect with his pistol after she
screamed for help
i should also mention that there was a
toddler in the residence at the time
that this happened a toddler that was
traumatized by what george floyd did a
woman who was traumatized by what george
floyd did
various people who were traumatized
throughout the life of george floyd he
left a wake of victims that is what
happened he had so many victims
throughout his life but right now
the world has decided that he's just a
wonderful human being you're not allowed
to talk about his record not a lot talk
about anything there are children that
are running around with george floyd
shirts there are murals that have been
constructed dedicated to george floyd
because his name has now become
synonymous with justice i guess my
question is justice for who how do i do
that how do i live a life so i think
that's her issues like you know like
if anything
now now this wasn't then but like kevin
samuels should get a mural but you don't
see that yeah you should do yeah what
they should do they should but they
don't they should like make him like the
poster boys of like obesity groups to
help obesity that's crazy too i'm pretty
sure trump trump is growing on me i used
to hate him
choke hold
hold the law
yeah look at it literally
they're rioting in the streets trump
immediately this man always did what he
said he was going to do trump signs
executive order banning chokeholds
unless an officer's life is at risk so
it's like they all made him seem like
you know what is is because he's so
eccentric and some of the things he did
now when i look into it he was just
doing it to be divisive
like him saying to build the wall and
then
um it all comes down to what's the
theory where they believe that if
uh hispanics and blacks keep populating
it the way they do
that eventually brown people would be
the ethnic majority in america
so and that's what we talked about with
the whole abortion idea this is why i'm
on the fence because
the reason why
they're doing it isn't to make women to
be more responsible is because i believe
the powers that be know that it's
educated white women are having the
abortions and less educated brown people
um are populating more so eventually i
think it's like 2067. they said america
will actually be white people
that's that's not correct
black people and brown people get
more abortions than white women than
getting them white women at their right
yeah i like that the black population
has a 50 birth rate in the us
uh from pregnancies yeah so is isn't it
more educated
white women and men well white women
sorry that are having abortions down
it's it's people with more money which
happens to be the what no no i'm saying
like black women get it at the highest
rate mexicans are after yeah but
planned parenthood and black or minority
communities they're the they're the main
consumer but in terms of populists
the ethnic minorities are populating
more than the white majority yeah
so that's why you talk about this
what's the theory called the separation
theory or the takeover theory and that's
what's fueled a lot of the shootings and
that's the reason why they're saying
that field watch shootings they're
saying that because this is i read the
new zealand manifesto you know the guy
that the shooting
in the mosque because if anything
abortion um
would be population control for minority
communities that's what um planned
parenthood was started as yeah
all right disproportionately the leading
consumer of the abortionist services is
the african-american female according to
the 2011 abortion surveillance report
issued by the center for disease control
black women make up 14 percent of the
child bearing population yet obtained
36.2 percent of reported abortions black
women have the highest abortion ratio in
the country with 474 abortions per 1000
live births percentages at these levels
illustrate that more than 19 million
black babies have been aborted since
1973. according to the department of
health of every state that a port that
reports abortion by ethnicity black
women disproportionately lead in the
numbers for example in mississippi 79
percent of abortions are obtained by
black women in dc more than 60 percent
in georgia 59.4 and alabama 58
in state after state similar numbers are
found with black women aborting at two
three or four times their presence in
the population at every income level
black women have higher abortion rates
than whites or hispanics except for
women below the poverty line where
hispanics have slightly higher rates
than black women
the prevalence of abortion facilities
within minority communities serves as a
major contributor to the rate at which
black women obtain abortions according
accordingly black women are five times
more likely to have abortions than white
women a recent study released by
protecting black life and outreach of
life institutes concluded that 79
percent of planned parenthood surgical
abortion facilities are strategically
located within walking distance of
african or hispanic communities this
study can
coincide with historical revelations
that eugenicists dating to the mid 1900s
argued that the most effective way they
could advance the agenda would be to
concentrate population control
facilities within targeted communities
and quote black women and abortion
abortion is the leading cause of death
for african americans more than all
other causes included including aids
violent crime accidents cancer and heart
disease and that nuts
u.s fertility rates so this is
supporting the replacement theory
yeah okay in 2001 there were about 4
million births in the united states and
a total fertility rate of 2.1 births per
woman minorities contributed 42 of all
births i believe that even though they
make up 31 percent of the population
one reason minorities accounted for a
disproportionate share of birth is that
a larger proportion of minority women
are
in their child-bearing ages but minority
women also have more children
than
non-hispanic white women on average i
believe
that you see that graph that it says
yeah the average number of births per
woman is three yeah it's it's it's a
it's a compound in effect so by the year
26 if they were to carry on yeah yeah
three times three rather than two times
two no i i agree with you like i would
say because why when people have more
money they tend to have less kids
so so i would that would like make sense
but that's what that's what the
grapefruit basically that's he that
three times three if that child then has
three rather than say the white people
are having one and a half one and a half
times one and a half compared to three
times three it compounds so that's what
they're talking about
with the great replacement theory
it
allows you're left there less likely
well that you're going to carry on
reproducing and this is less likely to
happen that's the premise
i think that would happen regardless
like with or without abortion yeah no i
agree
but if anything like abortion since like
black women are getting it more like
abortion would banning abortion would
help with the great replacement rather
than
because like let's say abortion was
banned tomorrow like black women are
getting the most abortions from yeah
well with the great replacement for you
too honestly that's why with the whole
building the wall it's fueled by
hispanics i just said browns but it's
mainly hispanic
black i can't speak of but the whole
great replacement theory yeah so fueled
by hispanics they're saying that that's
why they want to build the wall to stop
them from so i have a question if you
had a piece of land and you wanted to
stop someone from coming on it how would
you stop them no that that's that what
i'm talking about is the reason of why
they're stopping them from coming is
because of that really great replacement
for you they want to maintain america as
a whole no but i'm saying like how do
you know that
how do you know that yeah i know this is
us having a conversation i don't know
that oh
to me it's like you don't know why
someone's doing something but to me it's
like
i just feel like okay back then i didn't
understand why people are freaking out
because i'm just like if i have a piece
of land oh i think everyone agrees that
you have to monitor who's coming in yeah
i agree and
this is why people think
that this is the reason like trump went
against the elites this is this is this
conspiracy no evidence this is just like
what people think so and by him putting
the wall they rallied so heavily against
that and made him sound racist because
it's so racist
because because
they think that's where they would do
human trafficking so they that that's
like like trap human trafficking like
went down under trump i can believe that
because it's harder to get in
yeah but that's not the premise of why
he his was to stop [ __ ] countries
what he believed to be shared countries
for people coming in from [ __ ]
country
that's not the reason i get that's just
a byproduct of wait i do agree in terms
of like when you look at sweden and
norway yeah when they let in loads of
refugees the crime rate went [ __ ]
well i don't know i think it makes sense
like okay
if i'm gonna adopt a child right like
and it's an older kid i'm going to look
at their look at like
statistically what places have higher
crime rates yeah that's why you don't
you'd only adopt a baby because in the
kids
my parents adopted three
teenagers
was it mental
some good some not so good but like but
to me i don't think that's like racist
to say
like you have to
get get people that with less crime
rates yeah no that's but that's the
thing of i this whole thing is i'm not
one of the people with the lefties
you're saying it's racist but i'm saying
is
i'm not sure if what is motivating this
is just because women are controlling
their [ __ ] black and who they're
sleeping with i believe it might be
motivated by this that's my the only
point i'm making oh there's so i don't
think trump's a racist i think he uses
his words
on purpose i believe he said buildable
chinese violence
now that we're in media we kind of
understand what yeah
because um there's a guy that was killed
here called um
lee rigby he was like killed by like
some extremist guy so i'm a slim guy and
when the guy killed him he came on
camera and everyone was recording him
and again he beheaded the guy in the
middle of like a busy like london street
like blood all over his hands and he was
like an ex-army veteran and he did like
a manifesto speech to the people after
he killed the guy and he's just like i
never wanted to kill this guy but when
people are getting killed in syria all
my muslim brothers and sisters when i
say things politely you don't listen so
when i do something extreme
you now listen to my message and the
thing is that video went round and
people actually started listening to
what you're saying but if he didn't kill
that guy they wouldn't know so now when
you work in media that's the extreme
sometimes in order for people to take
your message that's why people come out
with outlandish teams and that's why you
see like even like you know certain
trolls that we've spoken about in the
past
they troll and the premise of what
they're saying yeah makes sense but
they've just hyper well it's like when i
say leave the whales i mean i mean it
but i mean like
people that get fat with no regard for
their husband at all you know what i
mean like there's there's nuance in that
that's what i would probably like i'll
say leave the where like yeah yeah
i could say oh promiscuous woman or i
could say dirty [ __ ] when you say dirty
or do you know oh that dude you go but
i'm like nice
and [ __ ]
but but
um i do think they'd be heading a little
too far too far yeah but it got the
message across though i don't think
there is a buy
no but it didn't get the message it's
mad i don't agree with it did it his
message made sense yeah the message but
like what policy is switched um i think
it was more just to raise awareness
because people just didn't know that's
like i don't understand this mentality
raise awareness that does nothing yeah
awareness without action it doesn't make
yeah he might now motivate obviously
hopefully not to go and other people to
do other things and you see him same way
when when did this happen
lee rigby type in lee rigby 2013 and
where was this at oh my god this is in
woolwich will it yeah that's like right
by us yeah it's out down the road willie
town center like madness just broad day
where am i where do i live
yeah you live in the ghetto now oh my
god
long way from the suburbs
oh my god okay let's watch the rest yeah
don't worry you don't get beheaded
you'll come so that people say candace
owens's name is synonymous for justice
it's not telling the truth people hate
that people say you're not allowed to
say it you're not allowed to talk about
who this person actually was because the
media has agreed on a narrative before
the truth has gotten out about who this
man was
getting his life together is anybody
still buying that anymore oh no never
mind it actually turns out that at the
time of his arrest he had fentanyl in
his system he also had methamphetamine
in his system we also learned that the
week prior he had had an overdose but
none of that matters
because now we live under mob rule mob
rule just says that if a black man dies
and a white person is around while that
black person dies it is a racially
motivated crime they've never proved
that nothing about this was about race
at all but it doesn't matter because now
george floyd has been propped up and
this is what we have to agree on what do
you think about that
um
because we know the history isn't it
obviously someone can correct me wrong
didn't derek shivan
and george floyd loosely know each other
from before and like he didn't really
like him apparently they worked in
security together or something like that
but then what if he just didn't like her
yeah he could just not like him just not
predicating his black you just might
just not like
you know i'm gonna show you have you
heard of daniel shaver nope
okay
yes yes yeah and he's just like don't
shoot me in this yeah yeah but nobody
ever like why wasn't he we heard about
that here though because you know we who
anti-guns and you are like yeah shoot
everyone so yeah this scenario could
never happen in england this is the
saddest thing i've ever seen
but like i didn't understand why
like
i don't know because i just have a hard
time like how how would you know if
someone's racist if they're just an
[ __ ] no the one thing is what i have
to agree with can this one is she
actually presented that
like unarmed unprovoked deaths between
blacks and whites in america it just
happens like there was no like
correlation or this black person that
gets it more like if you're black or
white
or whatever the guy's name he just said
like it happens to black and white
so um
that's something it's just crazy how big
of an issue it is when like by and large
it's really not that many people
united states
population
three like out of
329 million people
a thousand died yeah it's not really
that deep so i don't like it's just
weird that it's such a big issue
when it's like we should be marching the
streets for diabetes
yeah yeah
put the fork down
the thing is they don't want to march
they don't even want to [ __ ] walk
that's probably not
trying to do a much
that was funny that was funny
put the fork down deborah
diane
nobody's allowed to tell the truth
why aren't they doing this
why can't we honestly have an assessment
and come to an agreement by the way i
would have been perfectly comfortable
people said derek chauvin was guilty of
manslaughter i'm comfortable with that
charge i'm not comfortable with the lies
that have been told repeatedly about who
this man was if you care about black
lives if you're watching a sneaking
candace i just care about black lives
then why can't we discuss black
criminality at the same time because
usually on the other end of black
criminality is a black victim
that was the case with jacob blake that
was the case over and over again with
george floyd
that's also the case with and let's talk
about the person that was trending all
last night and all this morning makaya
bryant is that her name the woman the
the young woman that they're now saying
a 16 year old girl in columbus ohio who
was shot on tuesday by police
did you guys see the clip of of her
mother
er she was shot and killed by police
because she was attempting to stab
another girl it's on camera she was a
knife wielding maniac but those details
don't matter don't forget because her
mother came out and said that makaya had
a motherly nature about her
she promoted peace
kya bryant's mother wants you to know
only you guys see it as normal but it's
still very unnecessary just to be
killing people like in the uk because
not everyone's commissioned to have guns
people just get tasered like you have
people with mental health or people
robbing people and the police will just
come in and just taser you like i think
in america we're very quick just to
start shooting people like not even like
a leg shot or footstool you just start
shooting people like i actually i went
to a police academy school thing because
i used to sell copiers okay and i sold
the copier to this like wow
yeah like like the big it's the worst
job i've ever had but like like a big
copier like the ones that sit in the
office oh yeah and i sold one to like a
police like it's like um
it was a private police training like
they would hire them to either like
train security guards or police officers
so they're not trained to just shoot you
they're trained like if so if you have
your hands up and you reach
then they're trained to shoot because
you like you could be reaching for a gun
and it's really hard because it's like
at such a quick decision i got shot
every single time they let me play oh my
god i got shot but why can't you just
obviously this is because we don't have
guns as well actually we have guns if
you're from the from the end you know or
you'd say
you know there's guns everywhere
but we don't have guns as already
available so police aren't taught that
so it's you like if you get someone
who's knife wielding like her id was
talking about makaya right she was knife
rodent yeah that person will just get
tased and you'll get the same if you
have free man tasing you why do you need
to shoot that person because
okay because if she's got like a gun on
like on her
neck
as i'm saying in the uk we have loads of
situations there's loads of videos i'll
show you where they'll just tase you
like bear man get tased
i never i'm just saying like
why do you need to shoot someone because
obviously they've got like because
there's loads of people with mental
health there's ah you'll be knife
wielding in london there's loads of
videos yeah and they just taste them
like why do you need to shoot them to me
it's like you lost all your rights the
second you tried to kill no but that's
weird but that's when you're not valuing
life in a sense someone could be a
madman if you're a madman you need to be
tased and you need to be sectioned okay
you don't you don't need to be shocked
yeah if you're my man you are you just
killing my people you just need to put
them in a home give them some medication
i don't want to be i don't want to be
the one
you want to go watch them in the home
you're going to put that out
that's because you don't have to deal
with the problem yeah i pay my taxes
that's what they do
don't you guys have like isn't it hard
to fill jobs here like aren't you guys
yeah well the the us's economy is the
strongest at the moment how many i want
to know how many i'm just curious deaths
by police
happened in 2021 uk i'm just curious
the fatality
no not shot i said she won in the whole
year and that was probably yeah but
that's that's that's shot one person i
said how many died yeah people die
obviously in police custody
oh see look at it
united states united states oh i was
about to say
wow
wow
well well why don't they have this
number because not many people are dying
in the uk there is a oh wait a hundred
and ninety-one
police related deaths though that's
different please right now that's the
same thing you have to see the ins and
outs how many
people are in the uk
because police rated deaths could be hit
or well you guys percentage isn't much
better than ours it is you guys because
you're saying that's related
i please relate def could be i'm chasing
you in a hit um chasing after you see
road traffic fatalities and you crashed
the car oh i see that's not a [ __ ] i see
the police always actually i see so what
i'm just curious how many y'all got road
traffics fatal shootings one 20 and
police 20. oh you guys really don't see
19 in police custody wait 92 plus 50
a apparent suicides following custody
so 92 a hunt so you guys have like a
hundred and i mean if you look death in
police custody but that's actually not
so a hundred so we had a thousand
per year from from 300 something million
329 million you guys had 100 from 67
million no no but this is where it's
different that was just shootings death
in police custody if you die in police
custody you could have been buzzing on
drugs and overdoses no i just i just
took out the
car belgium no but death in police
custody that doesn't mean they killed
you you could have just died when you're
there like you could die of old age you
could have died from a drug overdose i
don't know that means you died
of a death durian of following police
contact what contact is that you could
have just he could have arrested you
next day you jump up a bridge like i
need to get a status to her account see
so all we can really go on
i don't think you i don't want youtube i
just don't think your numbers are that
much better than that no it's one
shooting that's the only definitive one
i don't think i don't think your numbers
are not that's better only one
i don't think your numbers are that much
you just said you believe in guys nah
nah but i believe every if everyone has
everyone should be able to have guns
like the teachers yeah i'm like i'm like
oprah you get a gun or you could be in
england where no one has a gun and
everyone's cool yeah i think i think i'd
be like oprah
you can have guns on the streets right
you can have guns for the streets if
you're on the streets you can have a gun
but you'll probably get some shitty like
little shotgun that nice rusty i'm like
i think everyone should be able to get
whatever gun they want i don't think so
you don't have stories here for kids
with ar15 shooting up schools because
that would never work in the you know
how big the us is um you think that
would work
shooting up schools they shoot up
schools like for banter
oh my god school shooting this is
another thing they act like school
shootings
us
per year
like
u.s
how many
people died
from school shooting no i'm not dying to
get shots because
because if you do a school shooting a
black 30 only let's say half are going
to die
how about how many school shootings
us 2021
school shootings
how many
34 school shootings all my days death
her injuries 68. that is too much why is
that they're out of health that's like
that's like not that many uh how many
people how many 300 how many people in
the uk though
329 million people in the u.s
how would they regulate
guns in this big of a country in a
freaking alaska what are you gonna do in
alaska but how many why how many school
shootings in the uk i thought probably
less you guys don't have guys zero but
you guys look at look at uk uk look at
uk map
you're telling me this is
this is what you got you guys are on a
freaking island yeah but we've got zero
see
how many stabbings yeah you guys have
more stabbings yeah we have a lot of
stubbornness to get going
but i'd rather get shot than get stabbed
i just i will die on this hill nobody's
gonna die
i would rather okay what does it matter
if you're dying yeah but it's gang
related
but you're talking about school
shootings people don't just go and start
knifing up schools
well yeah because they can't shoot as
many people yeah people don't do it okay
okay are there not teenagers that get
knives and stab each other yeah i'm gang
stuff yeah that's not related but they
don't go into a school and be like oh is
it bad replacement theory i'm just gonna
stop that pool
okay okay that was like one that was
like one shooting
stabbings you don't have some insolence
you know we should just rate it by
murders murders you at uk
wait uk
homicide
is it i don't actually know
500 oh that's not even bad 500 they're
in 594 homicide victims
oh ending in march yeah i don't think
that's for the whole oh yeah there you
go that can't be
i don't know so do five nine four times
12 should i just do 20 20.
so is it like they do it march to march
or is it 695 just i can't be just
murdered in that's only two two a day
in the whole of the uk okay so you don't
think that's right so you're saying
i don't know why that sounds quite low
if i'm honest
yeah i don't know
because my little my little town that i
used to live in
used to average three stabbings a week
oh okay so
oh murder rate well yeah here we go here
we go this is what i'm looking for
murder rate by country
okay so
you guys are not in the lowest murder
rate so humble yourself
humble yourself you know some of them
live under sharia law though look at
sharia law you have your head chopped up
oh here we go where are you guys at i
just want to see if we're we're still in
the blue though you lot in the red oh
damn
that's cause you love guns
i don't think so wait wait i want to
look down
so oh you guys are purple yeah you're a
purple
where are you guys is this you guys here
yeah
you think it's for real because we have
guns yeah i don't think it's because we
have guns
we'll hover up there we'll tell you the
homicide rate hover over england and it
tells you
where it tells you that so the homicide
it's all okay so it's low enough hey
109.
60 000. oh we have more people yeah but
we have more you have five times the
amount of people and you have 16 000
deaths yeah that's not like crazy that's
not looking good you ass
looking mad and she's asking you have
guns i don't think so
april oh i see australia yeah australia
is big but they get more guns now
australia they've got mad they've got
gun laws which should restrict it it's
interesting though because in the u.s
the cities with the most gun control
have higher crime rates i can be i can
believe that all right
that the knife-wielding maniac that you
saw is not who she really was maybe in
that moment she was trying to kill
somebody but the point that we should be
focused on is that micaiah bryant like
to promote peace in her spare time
right i mean this is like
i feel like we have now tapped in to
fiction now we have to just accept
fiction it doesn't matter because makaya
bryant was black and she died at the
hands of police officer and that's all
that matters now people want to come out
and they want to support micaiah bryant
maybe she too like george floyd will be
buried into a gold casket maybe
eventually one day nancy pelosi will say
that micaiah ryan's name will be
synonymous synonymous with justice
let me tell you what is actually
happening in america at this time if
you're a black american you better pay
attention
right now in america the goal is to make
sure that black people
love and support criminality
that is the goal the express goal now is
to make black people believe that we
should be in the streets rioting and
looting and demanding justice for
criminals right because that is what
these people are they're criminals
george floyd was in the process of
committing a crime i'm not saying he
deserved to die i don't think anybody
deserved a die i think he deserved to be
arrested they attempted to arrest him
did you forget that part have you seen
the full video of his arrest the media
refuses to show the full video that
shows the police tried to put him into
the vehicle multiple times and he
resisted arrest by saying i'm
claustrophobic i'm claustrophobic
because he had just ingested fentanyl
fentanyl that thing that's a hundred
times more potent than morphine but then
you come to a point of duty of care is
that the guy was high on drugs wherever
he's made that mistake but to equate
that that it's almost she's putting on
it's his fault that he died is he's
i don't think she's fair to say that
that's
that's neither or that's not a hero
there's like any other crime if if
someone was graped you'd never say to
them ah but they were right walking out
late at night or they're wearing that
type of clothing so for this kind of
crime
why is that used as a supplement to me
our kids
some
unlawful
lost their life i would well for grape
yeah i mean i think there's situations
you shouldn't put yourself in as a woman
and it's not something
i hate it just like i don't think it's
smart to resist arrest yeah i don't
think the small eye but what i'm saying
is she's almost trying to use that as an
argument and when if you were to switch
it to great i guarantee most of society
wouldn't allow that as an argument if
most of but we're in the free thinking
space here
and i i would never blame someone but i
would say hey
you can look at that situation yeah and
think maybe don't put yourself in that
situation yeah like everyone knows that
girl that wears that
goes out and has no way she's getting
home like she doesn't know how she's
getting yeah and it's like if you go out
at night wearing nothing that's like
i'm not i'm not saying like what do you
think is gonna happen but like honestly
if you're by yourself you don't have a
guy to protect you like what but can you
see my argument because even though we
are in the free thinking space can you
see how people are allowed this is an
argument but if you change it to grape
people would be like oh my god how could
she ever make this argument
i could see what you're saying i just
don't think like
it's right
because i just i think like you
shouldn't resist arrest from an officer
yeah and it puts both of you at risk
because now the officer like
you see in so many of these cases people
resisting arrest yeah i wouldn't do that
yeah it's just not smart
so
like i had a cousin that was addicted to
drugs and he had some bad interactions
with the police but i was like you know
what he's also crackhead
like
like a lot of the [ __ ] that like people
complained about he would complain about
but i'm like well
he's a crackhead like he would say
police robbed him
they might have i don't know but
at the end of the day my cousin was a
crackhead so like
what what value does the crackhead have
in terms of robbery like what are you
gonna do yeah he said if he ever had
cash on it and he would get arrested
like they would always take it
probably for his better so he doesn't
spend drugstore well i know that's still
illegal
but probably done in favors
like it i don't know
well actually funny thing is he actually
got
really like there was one time the
police did mistreat him and he proved it
and he got let off for the crime that he
committed that's sick yeah because they
um illegally searched him like they
didn't have a reason to search him
that's like our one of our friends we
had in the podcast he went to prison
then it got overturned
um but they didn't want to pay him
compensation so they said they gave him
like jail time on credit so if it goes
joe again
he gets tired
how long was he in jail uh he's done
like three years but he did an extra
like four months then he should have
said like if you ever come back you get
four months off
that is so [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up in
it because we even banned it we're like
oh so what did you get on credit is that
yeah i did
sorry i should have been laughing that's
a horrible yeah it's mad you see the
tick tock clip people were laughing
but um no with my cousin though like
honestly like
i don't know i just always be like i
need to crack it
like i'm sure some of the shitty was
complaining about was true but at the
end of the day i'm like why are you
cracking i do get it though like people
forget they're human because i used to
work in security here so like
like we call them bouncers but over
there you call them i don't know like
doormen and nightclubs and they don't
realize like at some point
people take the piss so much you're just
gonna end up beating someone up because
you asked them a million times you've
tried to remove them nicely
i'm just gonna choke you and remove you
because you're pissing me off now yeah
yes i hear it he had just ingested it
because he didn't want to again get
caught with a controlled substance as he
had done repeatedly throughout his life
let's ignore testimony from his
girlfriend who said that they were both
addicted which by the way that is sad
drug addiction is sad we can be talking
about drug addiction we should be
talking about drug addiction that would
be a meaningful discussion but instead
let's ignore all of these things that
would help us fix black america let's
let's not talk about drug abuse let's
not talk about drug dealers let's not
talk about criminality let's not talk
about why micaiah bryant had a knife and
was trying to stab a woman to death
let's just talk about black victimhood
because the discussion about black
victimhood
almost guarantees us that in the future
black neighborhoods are only going to
get worse
when you start celebrating criminals
that is of course what is going to be
the end result we're going to have more
black death we're going to produce more
black failures because we're not allowed
to talk about the truth anymore and
republican democrats are even saying
that this is good right so let's not
talk about it it's just been agreed the
lie has been agreed upon don't say
anything if you tell the truth candace
you're a bad person
i don't care what i am called just
because right now in this country we are
facing a pandemic of cowardice because
people are too scared once the mob says
that this is what must be said and these
are the only things that can be said
because the media has now created a
system a successful
system of propaganda where people don't
even know what the truth is because the
lie has been said over and over and over
again that does not mean that i'm going
to back down to the truth in fact i
think more than ever now we need to have
people that are willing to stand up and
to say that what is happening in this
country is wrong what is happening in
this country is backwards
none of these people that i mentioned
are heroes
thanks for joining me on this segment of
candace if you like this video subscribe
to this youtube channel and ring the
bell to get notifications on new videos
okay would you
so watching it back do you feel the same
way about her um i think when i first
watched candy's owns as we know the
institutions are very left i think i was
very deep
in my leftist side of thinking so
it doesn't bother me as it did as much
in the time i see where she's coming
from i think and one of the reasons i
watched but i'll say we'll just talk
about this one is
i feel like in many causes
that happen that are positive that
person might actually be a fat person
who's done a lot of things and no one
really talks about that and you can look
at about in terms of
us and uk history when you look at most
of our leaders have done some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but we only ever talk about the
good things so even though yeah i'm not
saying george floyd was a model to
society but the fact that science
positive i would say has come out of
this it came out of it that was positive
i say affirmative action giving people
chances i can only speak for the uk that
people wouldn't have usually happened in
terms of in the corporate work so over
here we have something called the 1975
sexual equality act where basically
means you
you can't
pick someone based on gender race
disability religion all of those
but it wasn't really being enforced and
now when you're looking now
and this is why i actually wrote my
dissertation on this in the uk black
africans not caribbeans are black
africans in the uk and indians
outperform the white working class
middle class and upper class through
primary school to university but then
when you actually come out to get jobs
black africans have the lowest level
employment throughout so now a lot of
play work workplaces
they're
the way they're picking based on cvs i
mean they're going to get the role but
they'd actually fulfill a quota where a
certain amount of people from a certain
amount of demographics so if you're from
a single parent household if you're say
black or whatever you'd have to go a
certain amount would have to go for the
interview if you get to the interview
and you're not good enough that's good
enough point you know it's not good
enough but before these people because
they didn't know people through nepotism
weren't even allowed to sit in the room
so now it's more they weren't allowed to
apply for the job no they just won't
weren't getting interviewed and they
weren't getting picked and that's why
you're looking at because i work in
investment management i've seen my space
since the blm more efficient minorities
are being given the opportunity because
before us
i work in the people's industry so the
reality is there's three rounds of
interviews i don't know it'll probably
be similar to you in the u.s you have
your vetting just to see if you're
competent for the role
then you have a thing called um star
questions where you go and you
they really test if you're really good
for a role then you have a third one
which is basically a popularity test you
go in there and people see do i want to
do i want to work with this guy if
you've gone to our ufc equivalent of
some prep school in harvard and yell and
then there's another guy who's from the
bronx everyone in the office is from
harvard or yeah
what are you going to pick my way up
because i'll be honest if loads of
people from my community came for the
interview i'm going to pick the guy from
my interview so it's that it's more
getting rid of those processes and
making it more aware so that's what i'm
saying it has leveled the playing field
isn't that racist
um what if you were to do that
or in terms of leveling the playing
field well no because aren't you
interviewing people based on like their
race no it's more it's more of a thing
of if you have the equal
grade and you have the equal but a lot
of what you said the uk cv is
educational achievement
bloody bloody blow all that all of that
stuff and then the rest of it is what
they really care about is at the bottom
of it
what gets you the job is
your extracurriculars so for me i was
lucky i played like academy level
i was of a pro team playing rugby so
when i went to interviews in my space
there's loads of people that worked
there so i was going to interviews oh do
you know thingy i'm like yeah i know him
he used to coach me there
already i kind of know that that's my
way in so it's just like a lot of people
are being judged and are did you go to
boat school at eaton did you go and do
this at oxford when then when you're
looking at a lot of working class where
should it be that was there a lot of
these people shouldn't like shouldn't
you be judged on your education yes but
that won't mean it's that little part
so it was a thing of
you can say you get a thousand cvs and i
see it now a thousand cv's of those
thousand 500 are good enough so now when
you look at the cv on the recruitment
side you're like
what
do they have that distinguishes them
from the pack because we can only
interview 20. yeah so i've didn't bid it
with recruitment where they'll be like
they'll get a woman that she comes on ah
let's go on facebook gotta say titch
show get rid of her ah this one he used
to do
rugby at oxford with me
uh same for rugby team hours he's
probably gonna get on with the team
because we used to do rugby there as
well so now you're picking people
for likenesses
on their extracurricular so it's got rid
of that way in the sense of okay now
they can't pick people of their
extroverts
you'd have to have to have a certain
amount so you'd have a certain amount
that would picked on that but you'd have
a certain amount where you would have to
fulfill a quota so it gives an equal
opportunity it's like if someone who
applied who was disabled
they'd be given the opportunity to get
an interview whereas before previously
in the past employers would be like
sorry he's disabled we're just not going
to employ it so now it's given everyone
an opportunity whereas before they want
it and what it comes down to when you
get to the interview
are you good enough it decides whether
you get the job yeah but like to me
that's racist why is that racist because
it's it's like you're saying to these
people they can't do it on their own
yeah but the thing is if
the whole organization is like
like i know you right
i i don't think you'd ever have a
problem getting a job
because you're driven you're smart i
don't know what's mad i did yeah
i had me personally i had a problem and
when i get get into myspace
because i'm from how long were you
unemployed
uh for me this is my way in
school you know it's safe nobody i'm
saying how long you said you had a
problem so how long were you going i
went befo when uh about a year
after uni and then okay well the way my
way that's kind of typical though after
school no but what i'm saying is in my
space
when i got to places because everyone in
my space
was white middle class don't work like
don't talk like me
they're way in as they've known someone
who worked at goldman sachs jp morgan
yeah dad owns a yacht or but i'm just
such a normal person i'm like one of the
only people who from nepotism hasn't
come through my firm
it's almost like the question they
always ask me is like how did you get
here because people like me don't exist
don't exist in my space
and that's why it's like the guy i work
with now
he came a similar route but
we're like
one of not many like when i talk about
what i do within my community they're
like what you actually got a job in them
because people like us we we're taught
from
education that
we don't work in these spaces it's just
i've seen the effects on quotas in the
us and it's typically not like good so
elaborate so so the one the one that i
think of is schools so and the reason is
like they would do something similar
with education where they wanted more
like black people in different schools
and the problem was they were accepting
black people that weren't qualified for
the job they weren't qualified for the
school in those groups the black kids
would fail out you know you know where
the uk difference differs to
america see it in america you're like
because to me like it shouldn't matter
what you look like like i feel like the
only thing that should matter is your
qualifications and your skills and and
and honestly your extracurriculars too
like because to me it's like it's like
anything
anything more than that if you're gonna
hire someone or even interview someone
based on race like i think that's racist
and it's condescending to the people in
that race no boys is to put measures in
place to stop nepotism and the reason
why i say that same in you now with
content creation nepotism yeah so that's
giving favor to family and friends and
people but why why can't i give like so
i'm starting a business now i think if i
want to hire my sister over a stranger
of course i'm going gonna do that i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that especially if there's nothing in
the government stopping
you who likely you're not related to me
right from starting your own business
yeah but then this is where it comes
with the 1975
sexual quality act where of corporations
when you get to a certain size you can't
you have to pick them based on talent
and that's the reason is because
otherwise it promotes just for the
elites and the people that maintain them
to keep hiring who they want and that's
not based on time but even so if if i'm
if i'm the reason i would pick my sister
or my brother is because like we come
from a very driven family right that's
why i would do it and i think i would
have a better odds of getting someone
good because
like if you're raised by a productive
father it makes sense that everybody's
gonna be productive right but the thing
is you could start a business and if if
your group of friends is more productive
you're gonna out you're gonna out
compete me
in the market that's why the market like
evens itself out when it comes to skills
i think what we're debating now is
family office versus corporation when
you're a corporation there's no linkage
there other than
your whiteness and your upbringing but
to put the problem with that is now
you're marginalizing a group where it's
basically like
from from birth
what do you mean by your whiteness
because there's corporations that are
started by people that aren't white but
the majority in the uk are the of
corporations or white fighters the
majority of the uk is white isn't it um
i believe
ninety percent of it is what i think so
of directors and ceos 0.3 are of ethnic
minority there's what not three percent
of directors of the foots
but like the thing is you don't know why
that is but if you're looking at i did
but it's not academia that's not it's
not talent because if you look at no no
who outperforms all the way through the
education system it's not the right word
right but like demographic yes but the
question is
it doesn't necessarily mean like my dad
wasn't very good at school he dropped
out of college but he's in the top half
a percent of earners like it doesn't
necessarily mean just because you're
good in school you're gonna make a lot
of money and a lot of times like what i
see the left argument make is there's a
disparity that ex that it's immediately
from discrimination or like nepotism or
something when oftentimes it's different
cultures value different things like for
example i would argue that indian
americans probably
they outpace
any group in terms of income but i would
guess they're probably a lower
percentage of ceos because they tend to
be programmers
and it's just like like germans tend to
make more money because they tend to be
engineers no but i know but this is what
i'm talking about in terms of
the the stuff you can even get out the
footy one like what puts you where i
think it's 55 100 directors or 5250 i
can't remember this is what i did my
discipline um
that is directly linked to academic
attainment this is when you're looking
at say property wealth and in the uk
indians own 74 of their homes compared
to any other demographic but they don't
make it they kill it everywhere yeah
it's their model which is like buy it
buy up land sell essentials and they
just smash it but when you look at say
um
blacks they have explored the academia
room
but landslide they weren't getting in
they weren't getting opportunities to
even sit at the table and that's where
the conversation was is there something
stopping black people from starting
their own business here um
in terms of
in terms of finances do they have the
available capital well if you look at in
the uk the majority of black people but
say if you wanted to start a business at
35 you've had from 18 to 35 to save to
do that no yeah that's you're
basing on the predication that that
person's from a stable upbringing but if
you're no i'm not my dad that's like
because he he grew up with one of 13
kids on the south side of chicago they
had no money he started off with like
two hundred thousand dollars in debt
yeah but so so and he didn't have his
parents didn't own a business nothing so
so what i'm saying is like he just made
smart decisions he didn't drink he
didn't go out he got married young he
just did all the right things but what
you're talking about is they call it the
winner's curse is where they hand pick
someone say like richard branson and say
oh he never got a degree and he's a the
ceo and i don't know a conglomerate but
how many other people the majority of
people with your dad's upbringing don't
have that success story right because
people coming from because
because most of them don't work 80 hours
a week
like from the time he was like 20. like
i i don't work 80 hours a week i might
do like 70.
i work
and what kind of earners your dad in
terms of percentage was probably 0.25
half a percent that's my point so your
dad you're using your dad your anecdote
as the elite and there's black men that
have done that but landslides people
coming from from your destiny
88 of 80 percent of millionaires are
self-made they didn't get any money so
so i'm saying like i i don't like a
quota to me is like just this is just my
perspective i think it's racist because
it's oftentimes like white liberals
saying oh to basically to minorities
they can't do it themselves and i think
a lot of times like i've talked to like
black conservatives that find them
offensive because they did it themselves
and they're like why do we need these
handouts but it's not being able to sit
at the table isn't a hand up because
you're not getting picked based on the
quote you're being given the opportunity
to have an interview when prior you
wouldn't have been able to right but to
me but that's still saying to them you
can't get an interview on your own
a lot of them can't for me i couldn't
get until i got the co-sign from a white
man that liked me i couldn't but the way
i got it is
right so you so that's what i'm saying
you you you got into because you
networked because i networked with a
white man who lost the power so that's
that's good you found someone that had
power and that happens to be the white
because we're
because we're in a white country we're
in a white country but i'm saying
because we're in a white continent what
does it matter like what he looks like
like that's the thing like i don't
understand this like mentality where
it's like oh well he's a white man with
power okay who cares like because you
have like you have likenesses towards
that person it's just it's just like a
lot of black time because this is now
not not necessarily like i hired five
people like three of them were black and
i i didn't care because last year's
actually anecdote when you look at no
but i'm sorry i know i know
but i'm saying i know a lot of people
that own businesses and if you make the
money money is green they don't give a
[ __ ] what you want as long as you're as
long as they're making the money well
what you're saying now is anecdotal
there's loads of businesses that don't
think that way well it's not just
anecdotal because i also take like into
account that 88 percent of millionaires
in the us are self-made
so so so what do you mean in terms of
so like they didn't inherit any money
it's not i know but what why are you
saying that's not and i'm talking about
in terms of hiring now we're talking
about hiring
i'm talking about wealth creation so
yeah we're talking about wealth creation
yeah and so i'm which goes into hiring
as part of it how many of that 88
million are self-made how many of them
have any minorities in the us
but to me like why does that matter
like that that's like the mentality i
don't get no because it's not if we're
talking quotas wise if say that of them
of them is is ten percent then that
would
that would equal
like per cap per capita would equal the
same when you're producing eight percent
or ten percent per the eighty days but
i'm saying it shouldn't matter because
like i i don't think like race matters
like i don't think so it doesn't matter
to you
it shouldn't it shouldn't and i agree
with that that's me coming as a mixed
race person like my mom's like
uh asian asian and white but that's me
coming from there my dad's bad honestly
it does the top burning income group is
indian america isn't it is indian
american in the us and the uk is the
same
so it's like if there's these barriers
that were so like
like then why are indian americans able
to do it now indian americans do yeah
because to me
right because it's more about culture
but
culture their culture
in terms of attainment is indians do
where the gujaratis when they go to
tanzania they go to kenya they do the
same thing theirs is pick up a shop
owner shop
con consumer staples just become the
masters of that no not in the us they're
all they're programmers oh and over here
is consumer stuff yeah they just well
i'm just saying their culture is very
much like hard work
and so it's like my question is and i
mean i could be wrong but it's just like
my question is like if indian americans
can do it in all these different places
like i don't understand like why other
groups need handouts like because to me
like i think that's racist because it's
basically liberal saying you can't do it
on your own
whether it's an interview whether it's a
school application but like it's all the
same concept yeah but when you look at
exactly i can talk about the uk yeah
there was policies and we'll get him up
because eddie was the one that told me
about it there was policies at the time
because in a lot of people near you from
the commonwealth
so that was jamaica and
a lot of caribbean and india came to the
uk
in the commonwealth um from the
commonwealth in the wind rush so i was
around the 60s
and there was actually policies at the
time where a lot of the corner shops in
the uk are owned by indians and not
by
the caribbeans that came because at the
time the government gave out policies
where
mortgages would be handed out to indians
rather than to
the black caribbean well see i would say
that's wrong too because again i think
like any policy based on race is wrong
whether it's like even if it's too late
level the playing field they call it
affirmative action yeah i understand the
intention it's just the a lot of times
like in like the path to hell is paved
the road to hell is paved on good
intentions and like i just think that
like if you're giving something to
someone based on race that is racist but
it's not you're not being given it you
still have to you're just being given
the opportunity and that's where i think
we're having a different system
even even if it's opportunity i think if
you were giving someone an interview
based on race that is racist just like i
think if someone was saying oh i'm only
going to interview white people i think
that's racist no but people this is my
point is people
this is now being openly put but people
will do that and have been doing that
just without overtly saying rich people
no i'm saying people before these
policies before the 1975 equality yeah
white companies were employing white
people way more than they were playing
any other ethnic group but when that was
put in place and
rules are put in place to tell people
that whether because a lot of people
talk about overt racism in the sense of
maybe racism in the world i'm talking
about prejudice acting on prejudice
everyone acts on prejudice so can i vote
can i talk to you the first thing you
said though you said white companies
were hiring white people but 90 of the
uk is white and you don't know why they
were hiring white people so it's like
the automatic assumption that it's
racism when you don't know certain
cultures want to do different things but
like you type in the 1975 equality and
we can do it now and if you see how
employment actually spikes within
marginalized groups that says it all
that people won't be giving
opportunities because why suddenly they
they're being employed because they they
now have the job so they obviously have
the talent because they're doing the job
so you wouldn't hire them if you didn't
have the talent you have to have the
talent
but i'm saying if they had quotas
wouldn't they automatically
and then it's like where does it end
when when are we equal that's the
question
sexual
titan 1975 race race for women i do
because that one's just women there's
one that's like sexual it's like race
sexism science
when you did your dissertation did you
look at um
no no so i'm curious did you look up
like the number of black people in the
uk did it go up over time too so yeah
like like because it was for it was for
what caribbean or african you said
um that was who it was protect like who
who gets the quotas oh yeah my friend my
sister said that to me
one because the other thing is like a
lot of times they'll attribute one
policy to another thing when you don't
know if um
if like that that group increased in
general in the uk
like if they had more migrant like if
more people immigrated here i think it
was based on quote from memory but let
me get a
i have a question so wait do you think
it should be illegal for you if you
wanted to do a black only business uh
black only business in terms of like you
only want to employ black people
um i think if it gets to a certain um
capacity there needs to be some kind of
legislation one thing i do agree where
we'll have to i do agree there is um
i do believe in a difference between
equality of outcome and equality of
opportunity uh that
at some point there is um
a difference who is the government
telling me who i can and can't interview
like that's my issue like why why does
the government know why i'm interviewing
people so should we women not be allowed
should there be no quota in place for
women yes i think do you believe in
maternal leave
okay this is what i believe i believe if
i start a business the government
doesn't get to say what i do with my
business
and if you and if i'm doing something
like only hiring white people or only
hiring women or only hiring men like
you're going to out-compete me because
i'm not getting the most skilled people
you know who you sound like
milton friedman he's the ultimate
economist like the godfather of
capitalism he believes that any business
owner as long as they abide by the laws
or society should be able to make money
in any way they want no matter who okay
like
okay like is the nba discriminating
against white people because what
because of talent yeah because i'm
saying if the nba doesn't have as many
like it has more black people in it
right so are they discriminating against
white people because they've been given
an opportunity to
travel for the nba yeah that's what i'm
saying
everyone gets the opportunity to start
their own business or apply for a job
and if you if you don't get the job go
start your own business yeah where would
be problematic if there was what if
there was skills that that were directly
transferable so such as
why nba let's say draftees were getting
the same numbers and then despite
getting the same numbers if not better
were being told no we we'd rather employ
someone in the nba who was like us even
though you're
a better player and a better stats and
you go start your own league and if you
have better players
that's what i'm talking about but that's
that's when it becomes of everyone has
the finances available right but i'm
saying if you start working at 18 and
you want to start the league at 35. okay
are you going to play in it you're not
going to play anything it might not be
you might be the next generation but i'm
sorry
so you don't have to be in that rock
where you have to wait for someone else
to
no or you can go start it yourself
that's what i'm saying like
money is green people want to make money
and so if they're really discriminating
against people that and that's the thing
like
it's just my opinion that people want to
make money they don't care who makes the
money no i see your point i'm not saying
that completely
i disagree but i i'm not saying you're
mad for thinking the way you believe
like i i it's purely capitalist yeah i
understand it but this was a fun convo
yeah i enjoyed it yeah good good talk
good time
we disagreed on some stuff we agreed on
something yeah that's good it's good but
i know your followers are just going to
be like oh my god this lefty and the
director of the red and white
okay um tell them where they can find
you guys
he agrees with me on a lot of stuff it's
just something something we disagree but
we did it on purpose because we know we
didn't want to come with all yeah
friends
yeah so so you should go subscribe to
their channel domino effect podcast find
us there i'm gonna debate me
pearl's been on it she's good jump on it
again episode coming out soon if you
don't subscribe or you disagree you'll
start calling me a sim i'll punch you up
see these guns come to the uk
actually smoke like the video on your
way out guys we'll talk to you next time